I want you to watch as one of CNN's law
enforcement analysts explains to CNN
hosts why illegal immigrants are more
likely to commit crime in New York than
in Florida these individuals I went over
their wrap sheets yesterday multiple
charges Grand Larsen robbery attempted
robbery grand larsy grand larsy uh this
particular crew operated on mopeds and
scooters they were doing organized
retail theft they were doing snatches on
the street one of them that they are
still seeking has 10 charges on one day
because he's part of a pattern that's
been going on and I'm looking at the
dates that their arrest started which is
probably close to when they got here
they've only been here a couple of
months so what the detectives are
telling me is they have Crews here that
operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
why don't they just stay in steal in
Florida and they said CU there you go to
jail so criminals are less likely to
commit crimes in places where they'll
where they will actually be punished